this is a story of nervousness and it
starts with a cacophony
at this shooting range in helsinki they
are honing their skills
among the people here members of
finland's huge army of reservists
the russian border is less than two
hours away they've looked at the war in
ukraine and shuddered at the idea that
it could happen here too
there's been a huge spike we have seen
now in the past month and a half more
new members in this period of six weeks
than what we typically see over like two
years
the war in ukraine weighs heavily on the
finnish people past soviet invasions
here have left a legacy of anxiety
for decades finland kept out of military
alliances but the foreign minister told
me his country now needed solidarity and
he pointed very clearly towards finally
joining nato
in finland we have been keeping in our
earlier white papers to the parliament
always this what we call a nato option
if security situation in europe changes
we are ready to look for the nato
membership and this is probably now the
change that we are ready to make that
step
the shop sells outdoor equipment and
military supplies sales have soared
recently from people preparing to either
fight or flee
so for example we have been selling a
lot
of backpacks right so what do they think
will happen when finland does sign up
with nato
immediately after we have left the
application then the sales will go up
momentarily it might take a week or two
because people are really
waiting for russia to act in some way of
course we don't know what it is it can
be a cyber attack
at least but we don't know so we but we
know the people we will prepare
planning for a russian attack is
something the finns have been doing for
a long time you just don't really notice
well here's the perfect example of how
finland carries on as normal while also
preparing for the very worst this
swimming pool was built underground
there's 15 meters of solid granite above
us and in less than a day it can be
drained and converted into a bomb
shelter capable of accommodating nearly
4 000 people
beneath the pool you can find the giant
blast doors even the curving entrance
road designed to withstand big
explosions
and we've been doing this for a long
time so
we have a
a heritage of preparing preparing and
it helps a lot
if something unordinary happens we are
not
paralyzed completely
we can keep the
society working
on the surface finland carries on as
normal but this is a nervous nation
fearful of its capricious neighbour
wary of the future
adam parsons sky news helsinki